Joe Biden had to answer more questions
than anyone else at last night's
Democratic presidential debate his
opponents strongly criticized the
Democrats frontrunner for his current
policies and his record Biden defended
his views on issues from immigration to
women's rights if you cross the border
illegally you should be able to be sent
back it's a crime it looks like one of
us has learned the lessons of the past
and one of us hasn't that's what we need
our politicians they have some guts on
this issue mr. vice president has said
that since the 1970s every major crime
bill every crime bill major and minor
has had his name on it this is one of
those instances where the house was set
on fire
and you claimed responsibility for those
laws there was nothing done for the
entire eight years he was mayor there's
nothing done to deal with the police
department that was crumble he wrote an
op-ed was that he believed that women
working outside the home would quote
create the deterioration of family he
also said that women who were working
outside the home were quote avoiding
responsibility you came to Syracuse
University with me and said it was
wonderful I'm passionate about the
concern making sure women are treated
equally I don't know what's happened
except that you're now running for
president button also went on the attack
slamming Medicare for all plans like the
ones being pushed by senators Kamala
Harris Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders Bernie acknowledges three trips
for 30 trillion dollars has to only be
paid and I don't know what math you do
in New York I don't know what Matt's you
do learn California but I tell you
that's a lot of money and there will be
a deductible the deductible be out of
your paycheck because that's what we
requires all right so let's hear what
senator Bernie Sanders says about all
that he's joins us from his home city of
Burlington Vermont talking about this
week's debates
first on CTM senator good morning good
morning how are you I know as we played
that clip from Joe Biden at last night's
debate you were shaking your head
already
he says there's gonna be a big
deductible
from people's paychecks under this
single-payer system he's basically
saying it's gonna be a big tax you don't
deny that do you look this is what I
believe and this is what the cases we
are now spending twice as much per
capita on health care as do the people
of any other country just a few days ago
as you may know I took a trip to Canada
with a number of people who are dealing
with diabetes we bought insulin in
Canada for one tenth of the price one
tenth of the price they were paying in
the United States the drug companies are
charging us the highest prices in the
world but last year they made 69 billion
dollars of profit the function of health
care must not be as is the case right
now for the drug companies and the
insurance companies to make huge profits
while 87 million Americans can't afford
the health care that they have the keiko
to the doctor when they want 30,000
people each he had died five hundred
thousand Americans go bankrupt because
of the medical bills that they can't
afford to pay this is an irrational
system we've got to do with the
Canadians and the people of every other
country do health care is a human right
we can cut the cost that people pay for
health care substantially by eliminating
the profiteering the complexity and the
bureaucracy of the current system but
Senator a CBS News poll found that
nearly two-thirds of Democrats think
that a national health care plan will
work better if it competes with private
insurance doesn't that suggest that
you're trying to sell something here
that Democratic voters may not want well
let me let me it all due respect push
back on you yeah there's just a poll
that came out the other day polls are
polls when you tell people were
following under a medicare-for-all you
will have freedom of choice with regard
to the doctor or the hospital that you
go to and let's also understand that on
the our bill we expand Medicare benefits
for the elderly to include dental care i
glasses and hearing aids which are not
now currently covered let's also be very
clear that every single year some 55 0
million americans change their health
insurance policies and
leave your job yes senator you've got
your right poles are our poles but you
know many people are frustrated with
their private health insurance you're
absolutely right about that but can you
convince a number of Americans to
support a federal system that will
actually be better than the private
market that poll that one seems to
suggest that people think competition
would be good no competition is terrible
in a health care the function of the
drug the function of an insurance
company is denied to deny you the claims
that you thought you had let's what the
function go ahead I'm sorry I just want
to kind of flip it around a little bit
here 2.7 million people are working in
the insurance industry which of those
people fears should they fear for their
own job security well what's the answer
is we have a just transition built in
the function of the health care system
should not be somebody sitting behind
the desk telling you that you are not
going to get the benefits that you
thought you had that you're going to be
denied that's a waste of money
function of a health care system should
not be giving hundreds of millions of
dollars in bonuses to an executive who
brings about a merger or huge
compensation packages for the CEOs of
the pharmaceutical industry so we're
talking about a just transition let's be
clear if you go to Canada right now and
you have heart surgery and you're in the
hospital for a month
you leave that hospital without a nickel
expense because they understand that
health care is a right senator
so come on yes go ahead sir I want to
say just you appeared in in the debate
the other night you appeared to have a
kind of a non-aggression pact with
Elizabeth Warren do you two have a deal
- not to attack each other at least at
this stage look Elizabeth and I have
been friends for over 20 years she's
running hard campaign and I'm running my
campaign they're different campaigns
what do you want I think the most I
think the most effective way to campaign
to be honest with you is to talk to the
American people about the why the middle
class is disappearing why we have
massive income and wealth inequality the
nature the great challenge we face in
terms of climate change the thievery
that it's now going on within the
pharmaceutical industry where there is
literally price fix
but there is just incredible greed you
talk about those issues you do well you
try to beat up on somebody else frankly
I don't think it's good politics so it's
senator at some point you and Elizabeth
Warren as most pundits seem to indicate
will make that that next debate how will
you differentiate yourself from her you
to progressives I'll tell you I'll let
you guys and the pundit tree and the
American people make that decision all
principle there what is the biggest
difference between you and senator
Sanders senator no no I have no I have
to tell the American people what I
believe and I'm gonna take on the greed
of Wall Street the drug companies the
insurance companies we are gonna tell
the fossil fuel industry that they
cannot continue to destroy this planet
for their short-term profits right now
the American people understand there is
something wrong when people are many
people are working longer hours for
lower wages 49% of all new income goes
to the top one percent that's my message
the American people we got to take on
corporate greed we got to create an
economy that works for all of us not
just the 1% that's my message that's
what I can't paint on all right senator
Sanders thank you so much for being with
us this morning my pleasure
thank you